le sens publique je vous propose un gros
plan sur un thème de campagne et les
propositions des candidates et des
candidats c'est demander le programme
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
souveraineté énergétique que propose les
principaux candidats sur ces thèmes
premiers éléments de réponse avec Sandra
cerquera
en toute logique l'environnement et la
pierre angulaire du programme de Yannick
Jadot il veut investir 10 milliards
d'euros par an pour la rénovation des
bâtiments sortir du nucléaire d'ici 2035
interdire la vente de véhicules neuf
avec un carburant fossile dès 2030 et la
fin des néonicotinoïdes et du glyphosate
nous soutiendrons massivement
l'agriculture biologique vous le savez
qui doit devenir notre modèle de
référence comme Yannick Jadot Anne
Hidalgo souhaite sortir du nucléaire
interdire les pesticides une prime
climat pour la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments et créer un impôt sur la
fortune climatique et bien sûr l'ISF qui
sera entièrement dédié à un fond qui
sera un fond d'accompagnement de la
transition écologique notamment pour les
plus modestes Jean-Luc Mélenchon a pour
objectif de baisser de 65% les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en 2030 pour
cela le candidat insoumis lancera un
plan massif de 200 milliards d'euros
financés par établissement de l'ISF et
les taxes sur les entreprises polluantes
l'interdiction des pesticides les plus
dangereux et des fermes usines est aussi
au cœur de son programme nous aurons un
ministère de la production alimentaire
et qui se souciera de savoir si nous
sommes souverains c'est-à-dire si nous
sommes capables de produire ce que nous
allons manger et de bonne qualité à
droite Valérie Pécresse n'interdira pas
tous les pesticides et sans remettre à
au ministère de l'Agriculture qui
avisera en fonction de chaque produit
son principal objectif la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 avec des incitations
financières pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
véhicules neufs fonctionnant avec des
énergies fossiles cette transition
écologique faut la financer moi je
fusionne le livret A et le Livret
Développement Durable je fais un livret
vert j'utilise 120 milliards d'euros de
ce livret vert comme Eric Zemmour Marine
Le Pen prévoit de mettre fin au projet
éolien pour préserver nos paysages et
souhaite développer le nucléaire en
faisant construire 14 nouveaux réacteurs
le nucléaire c'est aussi la priorité
d'Emmanuel Macron pour atteindre le à
neutralité carbone en 2050 avec la
construction de 6 à 14 réacteurs
européen l'énergie nucléaire et
l'énergie non-intermittente qui émet le
moins de CO2
le GIEC le confirme la Commission
européenne le souligne la planification
écologique du président candidat passera
aussi par la rénovation de 700 000
logements chaque année
et pour débattre autour de ces
programmes je vous présente mes invités
Gérard Longuet bonsoir sénateurs LR de
la Meuse anciens ministre de l'Industrie
Léa entre autres les emballages et le
mari qui bonsoir membre de la direction
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts adjointe à
la vie associative alimentation durable
et repas scolaire à Paris dans le 18e
arrondissement Jérôme du Rhin bonsoir
sénateurs socialiste de Saône-et-Loire
laetitia cruppa est restée à mes côtés
évidemment je commence avec vous les
emballages parce que on vient d'entendre
le témoignage
sur la souveraineté alimentaire et les
enjeux autour du blé vous entendiez ce
que disait l'expert peut-être juste
avant de d'arriver ce qui semble
contradictoire entre
la volonté de l'Europe de passer au bio
et donc de réduire sa production et les
enjeux de souveraineté alimentaire qui
sont posés par la guerre depuis plus de
3 semaines en Ukraine est à moi la
production de céréales et le blé est-ce
que vous vous dites pas bon bah
finalement notre modèle il est il prend
du peu obsolète ou en tout cas de cette
promesse il faut revenir au contraire au
contraire il faut et comment on fait
alors comment on fait si il faut trouver
l'alternative au blé qui était produit
en Russie ou en Ukraine en réalité
concernant l'alimentation et le blé
singulièrement c'est pas une question
d'offre mais plutôt de répartition du
blé quand on regarde le gaspillage du
blé en Europe c'est la moitié des
exportations du crâne donc il y a aussi
une question de travailler comment
est-ce qu'on traite le blé comment
est-ce qu'on lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire en Europe et puis ensuite
comment est-ce qu'on le répartit plus
justement on a en réalité plusieurs
plusieurs pays qui pourraient bénéficier
d'exportation de surplus de stock qui
existe actuellement et donc il faut
organiser cette souveraineté et cette
solidarité entre les États sur plus de
stock principalement en Europe où il y a
eu des surplus de stocks qui ont été
constitués et on a aussi toute la
question bien entendu de la de
l'indépendance de notre modèle quand on
parle des engrais azotés etc ce ne sont
pas
véritablement des modèles indépendants
et quand on parlait j'entendais votre
expert mais qui était plutôt un
lobbyiste d'une certaine agro-industrie
alimentaire il parlait d'une agriculture
forte l'agriculture forte c'est celle
qui fait vivre les paysannes et les
paysans celles qui évitent que un quart
des paysannes et des paysans vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté et que
l'alimentation devienne de plus en plus
cher alors qu'elle est de mauvaise
qualité pour un certain nombre de
Françaises et de français Gérard sur cet
aspect là mais plus généralement sur les
les conséquences de cette guerre en
Ukraine et est-ce que vous diriez que ça
ça fait durablement
changer notre réflexion et peut-être
même la réflexion d'une partie de des
écologistes européens par exemple en
matière de souveraineté énergétique
est-ce qu'il faut changer de pied à
l'aune des leçons de cette dans le thème
de l'indépendance en tous les cas quand
on a la responsabilité de la France et
de l'Europe ce qui sera la vocation du
président de la République française et
notre participation à la construction
européenne on était obligé de voir quels
sont les fragilités d'une économie
totalement mondialisée qui a de mon
point de vue beaucoup davantage et qui a
des faiblesses on le voit bien avec la
paralysie des exportations russes et
ukrainiennes de céréales dont le monde a
besoin un chat madame parce que la
démographie commande la nourriture et la
consommation de céréales quand la moitié
de gaspillage j'aimerais que vous me le
précisiez parce que c'est un chiffre
parfaitement fantaisiste pas du tout
alors vous pouvez regarder une tribune
qui a été écrite par 450 scientifiques
par exemple que nourrir les animaux
nourrir les poulets c'est le gaspillage
il y a énormément par exemple de blé qui
est utilisé pour la question des
carburants également actuellement en
Europe très très peu de blé non il y a
un peu de maïs il y a surtout du colza
pour faire du diester c'est-à-dire de
des huiles mais elles peuvent se
reconvertir et
une en Europe c'est la règle européenne
les l'incorporation de carburant
végétaux ne peut pas se faire sur des
surfaces dédiées à l'agriculture
que vous parliez de modèle qui doit
changer d'indépendance en réalité le
modèle qui a été construit depuis ses 30
derniers années ne nous prépare pas aux
crises que nous connaissons il a permis
les délocalisations des entreprises qui
produisaient les médicaments qui étaient
nécessaires pendant la crise sanitaire
il a organisé la délocalisation des
industries qui sont nécessaires pour
construire fabriquer les masques par
exemple on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire ou bien engager la transition
énergétique quand on voit que en réalité
nous ne pouvons le savoir faire français
n'existe plus sur le territoire pour un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui sont
indispensables à la transition
énergétique et enfin sur l'alimentation
nous avons un vrai sujet c'est à dire
que nous avons une inégalité de l'accès
à une alimentation de qualité et je le
vois très concrètement parce que je suis
adjointe à l'alimentation dans un
arrondissement populaire ou la cantine
scolaire et le seul lieu où on a besoin
on a la capacité de pouvoir développer
une alimentation de qualité notamment
une alimentation bio pour limiter les
effets de la malbouffe sur la santé des
enfants et quand je vais juste terminer
le bilan actuel du président Macron
c'est moins de 6% d'alimentation bio sur
l'ensemble de l'alimentation scolaire
alors qu'on devait avoir un objectif de
20% donc toute cette transition
merci puisque on vous a pas encore
entendu est-ce que l'Europe doit
finalement changer sa politique à l'aune
en matière de souveraineté alimentaire
et de et d'objectif de production à
l'aune de cette crise et de cette guerre
en Ukraine mais il est évident que la
crise en Ukraine elle modifie et les
données et que l'indépendance
alimentaire est souvent alimentaire elle
est pas
possible à 100% donc il faut tenir
compte de cette réalité je peux
géopolitique ça ne dispense pas et c'est
ce que propose Daniel Go de changer de
modèle de production parce qu'il y a la
souveraineté il y a la qualité il y a le
revenu moi je suis d'un département
agricole où on produit notamment de la
viande on sait que l'agrément
l'agriculture de qualité les signes de
qualité ne suffisent pas toujours pour
nourrir dignement les agriculteurs qui
en vivent avec des tarifs qui sont trop
bas et que du coup la mutation elle se
perd dans les territoires il y a la
géopolitiques il y a l'Ukraine il y a
l'Europe il y a les cours mondiaux et il
y a ce qui se passe dans un territoire
les projets alimentaires territoriaux la
relocalisation de production locale les
abattoirs locaux pour pouvoir produire
localement et les collectivités par la
restauration collective les
collectivités locales quand elles
encouragent des magasins de producteurs
ça aide à avoir du revenu local des
productions mieux payées et un vrai lien
entre l'agriculture
et le consommateur dans une alimentation
on peut rester sur la même tendance de
bascule vers le bio et assurer la
souveraineté alimentaire de l'Europe il
y a pas que le bio il faut pas se
focaliser sur le bio si le bio c'est des
champs de 80 km à 1000 km d'ici dans des
conditions qui sont industrielles sur le
territoire français
on a des productions de qualité qui ne
sont pas nécessairement bio moi j'achète
du vin chez un viticulteurs parce qu'on
en produit en Saône-et-Loire du très bon
qui fait du bio quand c'est possible et
quelques années ils traitent parce qu'il
est obligé de le faire donc on peut
aussi évoluer et être un petit peu moins
crispé sur ces signes là mais faire
faire émerger une nouvelle génération
d'agriculteurs avec ces standards là et
ensuite je crois que la politique
européenne agricole telle qu'elle se
dessinait avant la crise ukrainienne
c'est-à-dire de l'exploitation à la
fourchette d'une aimable plaisanterie
qu'il à laquelle il renoncer parce
qu'elle n'est pas capable
quantitativement d'assumer
l'indépendance
alimentaire de l'Europe parce que la
production est insuffisante parce que
nous avons besoin d'avoir des d'utiliser
les atouts dans certains secteurs ou la
quantité l'emporte peut-être sur
l'originalité nous avons des terroirs
qui permettent au contraire en
Saône-et-Loire pays de vin s'il en est
où on peut en effet jouer la qualité et
la proximité de bassin de consommation
mais laissons les professionnels gérer
leur métier ils font ça depuis très
longtemps c'est leur vie et c'est un
résultat positif puisque la France alors
est en train de régresser la France est
en train de régresser ces modèles qui
est
la plus aussi être imposé par l'Europe
encadré dynamiser par l'organisation
professionnelle et notamment par le
monde coopérative moi j'ai beaucoup plus
confiance dans les agriculteurs qui
vivent de leur travail
ceux qui commentent le travail des
agriculteurs chers madame ce que vous
faites avec beaucoup de talents certes
mais beaucoup d'éloignement des réalités
alors
pour reprendre un peu sur le modèle
productiviste est-ce qu'il nous a permis
d'atteindre une souveraineté alimentaire
non est-ce qu'il nous permet de
rémunérer justement les paysannes et les
paysans non est-ce qu'ils nous permet
paysans c'est complètement rétro chez
Madame pas du tout parler
et ensuite est-ce qu'il nous permet
est-ce que ce modèle productiviste nous
permet est-ce que ce modèle peut-il s'il
vous plaît merci est-ce que ce modèle
productivisme nous permet également de
préserver la qualité de nos sols non
plus et nous avons des agriculteurs des
paysannes ou des paysans qui sont
surendettés dont Yannick Jadot propose
de reprendre les dettes pour les sortir
de ce système notamment qu'il les a mis
vraiment le pied devant le mur parce que
on avait un modèle où non seulement ils
ont été abreuvés de Monsanto mais en
plus de dette qui ils ont empêché de
pouvoir développer un modèle qui leur
parle parce que je voudrais qu'on parle
de mix énergétique après il y a aussi
beaucoup de choses à dire surtout les
sujets environnement Toronto on est dans
une logique de transition
et on va pas passer du jour au lendemain
d'une agriculture qui a été conçue pour
nourrir le plus grand nombre pour
exporter à une agriculture micro locale
mais il y a une transition moi j'ai des
exemples très concrets dans mon
département un éleveur qui avait
plusieurs centaines de vaches et qui se
rend compte qu'en faisant 30 ports de
plein air à côté de son exploitation il
dégage autant de revenus avec ses 30
cochons c'est presque rien qu'avec une
exploitation gigantesque donc voilà on a
des transitions douces comme ça et je
pense qu'il faut accompagner ce
mouvement et c'est beaucoup qu'au niveau
local que ça sera j'insiste à suivre les
collectivités dans leur capacité
d'organisation les intercommunalités les
abattoirs de proximité j'y insiste ça
permet d'avoir cette transition et on
arrivera à ce que ce qu'on souhaite des
revenus des perspectives et de la
considération aussi parce que dans la
dernière période les agriculteurs
avaient pas beaucoup de considération
alors on parle du c’était attaqué
systématiquement par des des groupes
actifs activistes qui leur refusait tout
accès au progrès je le vois par exemple
je suis en désaccord total par exemple
sur les nouvelles techniques de de
production et de sélection de végétaux
par exemple nous avons le droit d'être
moderne nous avons même le devoir d'être
innovant et votre famille d'idées votre
idéologie conduit comme on l'a vu
récemment avec un train de céréales de
1500 tonnes qui étaient vidées sur le
ballast qui est parfaitement un vrai
semblable quand on voit des pays
craindre la disette vous en êtes à
déverser sur le ballast du chemin de fer
1500 tonnes de céréales parce qu'il ne
vous plaisent pas qu'il soit distribués
c'est simplement absurde il y a trop
d'ileurs laisser les professionnels
vivre leur vie je suis obligé de
redonner la parole aller à balade
la modernité monsieur c'est de se
prémunir contre les effets du
réchauffement climatique et ce n'est pas
votre génération c'est la mienne qui va
en connaître la plupart des conséquences
c'est ma génération qui a peur de faire
des enfants
à vous excuser non
ce que j'ai continué mon propos et en
réalité c'est ça la modernité donc je
m'intéressant à l'avenir que vous alors
monsieur je la modernité c'est aussi
peut-être de me laisser terminer ma
phrase et donc cette modernité c'est de
comment est-ce qu'on doit changer de
modèle dans les dix années qui arrivent
vous avez vu le dernier rapport du GIEC
il était froyable le prochain celui qui
sort le 4 avril sera tout autant
effroyable pour les conséquences et nous
le voyons nous ne sommes pas du tout
dans les perspectives de l'accord de
Paris qui nous avait liés collectivement
non seulement les plus riches continuent
à polluer plus mais en plus les plus
pauvres plus de continuer sur la
souveraineté énergétique cette fois-ci
et je vous propose d'entendre ce qu'on
disait le président du Medef geoffroyau
de Bézieux c'était sur notre chaîne sur
Public Sénat hier soir pour accélérer
alors là c'est un sujet compliqué mais
il faut aussi je pense une loi
d'habilitation pour les parcs éoliens
moi ils sont comme antenne devant chez
moi j'ai le premier parc éolien qui va
vous misez je vais vous répondre non
mais je suis citoyen et voilà ça fait
partie de un moment il faut aussi
accepter que si on veut se passer du gaz
russe si on veut
contribuer au non-réchauffement de la
planète enfin ou du moins limiter le
réchauffement il faut des éoliennes il
faut il faut bien quelque part on peut
accélérer cette transition il faut des
investissements il faut des lois
d'habitation qui
raccourcissent tous les recours divers
et variés et puis un moment il faut une
décision alors à faire un peu de
pédagogie tout de suite grâce à Fanny
rebond soit Fanny Fanny contre dans ce
sens public sur ce mix énergétique de
quoi on parle alors qu'est-ce que le mix
énergétique Lumix énergétique on
rappelle que c'est la répartition des
différentes sources qui sont utilisées
pour produire de l'électricité de la
chaleur du froid que ce soit pour les
industries pour les particuliers ou
encore les carburants pour les
transports par exemple regardez sur le
site du ministère de la transition
écologique voici la répartition que l'on
trouve pour le mix énergétique en 2020
aujourd'hui le mix énergétique dépend
encore à 60% des énergies fossiles en
effet on voit que les énergies
renouvelables thermiques c'est 10% les
produits pétroliers encore 41% le gaz
naturel près de 20% et puis
l'électricité présent représente 25% de
ce mix on peut justement se plonger
maintenant je vous propose de regarder
dans le détail ce mix électrique cette
fois-ci regardez les données sur le site
du ministère à nouveau le nucléaire on
sait c'est 67% de ce mix électrique la
France on le sait est très dépendante au
nucléaire l'hydraulique c'est 13%
l'éolien près de 8% le thermique 7 et
demi et puis l'énergie solaire seulement
deux et demi pour fantôme que prévoit
les politiques de transition écologique
là aussi sur le site exactement
qui a été votée en 2015 prévoit des
programmations pluriannuelles de
l'énergie les PPE ce sont des outils de
pilotage qui fixent des objectifs pour
la politique énergétique pour plusieurs
années alors on ne sait pas ce qu'il en
sera après l'élection présidentielle
évidemment mais pour le moment ce qui
est prévu dans les textes regardez
quelques exemples pour la période
2019-2020 il faudrait par exemple
baisser à 50% la part du nucléaire dans
la production électrique à horizon 2035
réduire les émissions de CO2 de 40% en
2028 par rapport à 1990 réduire la
consommation primaire des énergies
fossiles 35% entre 2012 et 2028 et puis
amener la part des énergies
renouvelables à 33% en 2030 merci
beaucoup pour tous ces chiffres il y en
avait beaucoup mais c'était très clair
merci Fanny je voudrais faire alors là
encore on continue de zoomer on est
parti du mix énergétique ensuite le mix
électrique et on va zoomer sur le le
nucléaire j'ai la longueur vous défendez
depuis longtemps le soutien à l'énergie
nucléaire qui nous rend alors là aussi
on est dans l'actualité évidemment
beaucoup moins dépendant du du gaz russe
est-ce que vous diriez qu'on a pris du
retard depuis je sais pas 10 ans oui oui
parce que le
mix énergétique repose sur une
perspective de consommation énergétique
et nous avons nous Français
l'administration française c'est pas le
Parlement qui a voté cela car la PPE
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
est une décision administrative à
sous-évaluer la consommation d'énergie
et d'énergie électrique en particulier
nous avons imaginé ils ont imaginé je
n'ai pas j'ai pas été consulté comme
parlementaire que nous pourrions
stabiliser la consommation électrique
c'est simplement impossible parce que en
effet la mobilité électrique est utile
parce que l'intelligence artificielle
amène une consommation électrique
importante et parce que le chauffage
électrique nouveau pompe à chaleur
issue du nucléaire et d'un chauffage
décarbonée or nous sommes trompés et en
effet il y a un retard qui a été pris
heureusement au centrales dure plus
longtemps mais il faut renouveler ce
parc nucléaire et il faut les conditions
économiques stables pour que ce
renouvellement soit possible soit des
lois et d'ailleurs très active dans ce
domaine puisque c'est le Creusot et
Chalon-sur-Saône qui sont les principaux
bénéficiaires de la commande Framatome
durant la fermeture de Fessenheim c'est
une décision du dernier président
socialiste en France François Hollande
est-ce que c'était avec le recul on
dirait que c'était une erreur
ce qu'on considère aujourd'hui à l'aune
des événements géopolitiques et
l'inaction climatique
quinquennat Macron aussi puisque
François Hollande a été la fermeture de
Fessenheim c'était aussi l'accord de
Paris c'était la COP 21 et c'était une
trajectoire climatique assez
volontariste ce qu'on a complètement
perdu pendant ce qu'un Canada la
modernité on en parlait tout à l'heure
en matière de l'environnement elle
n'était pas du côté d'Emmanuel Macron
pendant lambda je pense que ce qu'il
faut considérer et Anne Hidalgo le dit
d'ailleurs c'est que l'énergie nucléaire
est une énergie transition elle n'est
pas favorable à la création de nouveaux
réacteurs elle est sur le scénario 2 de
RTE
d'électricité qui a proposé 5 ou 6
scénarios l'ADEME aussi l'agence de la
transition écologique a proposé les
siens sont des outils pour les
politiques pour faire leur piloter pour
programmer pour anticiper et l'hypothèse
de travail le choix volontariste canal
Goffin c'est d'avoir l'é s'agit des
carbonées avec 100% d'énergie
renouvelable en 2050 ça suppose de
continuer à utiliser nucléaire
de nouveau réacteurs cinq dispense pas
de travailler par ailleurs sur la
sobriété parce que c'est aussi un sujet
nucléaire et pour quand dans le projet
d'adidalgo la sortie nucléaire elle est
forcément à cet horizontale puisque 100%
d'énergie
vous vous maintenez cet objectif malgré
la crise actuelle
c'est une perspective qui est fixée par
la candidate avec qui n'est pas dans le
déni du nucléaire comme d'autres
formations politiques sont Léa est-ce
que ce qui se passe depuis trois
semaines ça ça rend pas le logiciel
anti-nucléaire qui était celui des
verres allemands qui est aussi celui
d'une grande partie des vers français
totalement obsolètes au contraire au
contraire ça
nécessite dans un déni de réalité là non
le déni de réalité ce serait de dire il
faut faire comme avant ne pas anticiper
une crise qui peuvent arriver et ne pas
faire une transition de notre modèle
énergétique pour qu'on ne puisse pas
dépendre d'autres États et qu'on puisse
dépendre simplement de de l'eau du vent
et du soleil avec lesquels a priori non
n'entreront pas en conflit et donc là la
solution que propose Yannick Jadot elle
est très pragmatique elle est très
ancrée dans le réel c'est à dire la
fermeture progressive des centrales au
fur et à mesure de leur obsolescence et
par ailleurs la montée en puissance des
énergies renouvelables c'est aussi
simple que ça et ça ça va fonctionner
quand la sortie définitive du nucléaire
vous avez à peu près en 2035 on n'a pas
fixé une date précise mais si on doit
mettre deux ans ou trois ans de plus on
le fera si c'est deux ans ou trois ans
de moins on le fera aussi je vous
propose d'écouter je vais vous redonner
la parole juste on écoute un extrait de
la dernière prise de position du
président de la République il était 300
est-ce que on pourrait ne pas parler
tout ça en même temps merci Laetitia
Emmanuel Macron pas encore candidat donc
le président de la République quand il
annonce la construction de six nouveaux
EPR 2
je souhaite que 6 EPR 2 soient
construits et que nous lançons les
études sur la construction de 8 EPR 2
additionnels
nous avons ainsi Parlier la clé pour
produire cette électricité de manière la
plus décarbonée
la plus sûre
la plus souveraine et justement d'avoir
une stratégie plurielle celle que nous
avons choisie sur la base de ces travaux
et de développer tout à la fois les
énergies renouvelables et le nucléaire
alors évidemment il a changé de pied sur
la question nucléaire parce qu'il a
commencé son mandat en fermant
Fessenheim même si c'était la décision
du président
précédent Gérard longhia vous dites quoi
bravo enfin je dis que pour réaliser le
programme de Valérie Pécresse il vaut
mieux Valérie Pécresse qu'une imitation
comme on veut vouliez réagir à ces
propos de non je réagis parce que je
suis le sénateur d'un département qui
produit les cuves les générateurs de
vapeur au Creusot et à Chalon-sur-Saône
comme on a dit Gérard Longuet et il y a
un aspect qu'on ne traite peu trop
rarement c'est l'aspect des compétences
de la sûreté ce que dit Anne Hidalgo
c'est-à-dire que on va fermer les
centrales mais s'il faut avoir de
nouvelles autorisations d'exploitation
pour permettre de de d'assurer cette
transition d'éviter la hausse des prix
de l'énergie sous le contrôle du
Parlement sous le contrôle de l'autorité
de sécurité nucléaire il faut le faire
et et même si on s'achemine vers la
sortie du nucléaire et c'est un horizon
qui arrive on peut dire on va en faire
mais on voit qu'à l'échelle humaine il
faudra sortir du nucléaire on a des
compétences là pour continuer à faire
tourner continuer à maintenir démanteler
on a du travail pour des décennies
encore devant nous et c'est compétences
elles sont précieuses et je pense que ce
point là on traite il va falloir
recruter des des milliers de
d'ingénieurs par exemple c'est un des
thèmes que vous avez porté au Sénat je
suis pas sûr que les compétences on les
aient forcément là tout de suite sous la
main quoi on les a peut-être pas tout de
suite mais s'il y a un signal clair il
faut deux signaux très clair le premier
c'est une tarification de l'électricité
qui soit réaliste et qui nous fasse pas
dépendre de la plus mauvaise centrale
thermique allemande qui met en général
marche au charbon ça c'est la la
première réalité la deuxième c'est qu'en
matière de nucléaire il faut savoir
évoluer et il y aura sans doute de
nouveaux équipements plus simples et
simplement pour le les imaginer il faut
que le prix soit stable et qu'en
particulier la tonne de CO2 je crois
qu'on sera peut-être d'accord sur ce
point continue d'augmenter d'une façon
certaine pour que tous les investisseurs
qu'ils soient industriels transporteur
ou producteur d'énergie et l'obligation
absolue d'intégrer la décarbonation
comme un devoir et comme une réalité
économique positive ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui allez on va
tirer encore cinq ans ou 10 ans de plus
c'est très mauvais
cette décision annoncée par Emmanuel
Macron alors il le fait évidemment sa
stratégie depuis plusieurs mois c'est de
c'est d'enjamber la présidentielle de ce
de faire comme s'il était déjà élu mais
vous dites quoi vous dites c'est pas
cohérent c'est pas cohérent avec les
enjeux notamment
urgents qui sont qui sont liés aux
rapports du GIEC c'est pour 2040 c'est
pour 2040 pour des coûts qu'on imagine
pas
le dernier en date le Pr qui maintenant
nous coûte 19 milliards et qui n'est
même pas mis en service 19 milliards
c'est le budget de l'enseignement
supérieur un Flamanville tout à fait et
donc là on se retrouve avec des projets
des prototypes on ne sait pas très bien
comment avec soi-disant des mini
centrales mais en fait c'est des maximes
c'est pas les milices mais on a on a
plusieurs projets qui arrivent qui sont
un peu fantasques avec un horizon 2040
2035 dont on ne connaît pas les effets
donc on ne connaîtrait
ce sont les énergies renouvelables ce
sont les énergies renouvelables non
seulement c'est beaucoup plus productif
en terme d'emploi ça permet de faire
vivre les territoires et c'est aussi
l'indépendance énergétique et on en a
vraiment besoin on est un peu sur le
bilan du quinquennat Macron Laetitia il
y a eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat vous êtes posé ces questions
cette question qu'est-ce qu'il en reste
alors à son nom une photo peut-être avec
les 150 citoyens tirés au sort et puis
des archives radio et télé qu'on va
regarder voilà des chansons des images
des belles images de démocratie
participative et puis surtout des
renoncements Thomas le dernier en date
c'était en juillet quand Jean Castex
annonce lui-même et c'est lui qui prend
en charge cette annonce et pas Emmanuel
Macron que finalement il n'y aurait pas
de révision de l'article la fin de la
Constitution vous savez pour inclure la
protection de l'environnement c'était
une des mesures phares de cette
convention citoyenne alors Emmanuel
Macron s'était donné trois jokers alors
il a pris son premier Joker avec ce
renoncement ensuite il a dit non au 110
km/h sur autoroute et puis non à la taxe
sur les dividendes mais en réalité il y
a eu 8 jokers de l'exécution
c'est ça il y avait 149 propositions
donc 8 Joker Defacto et puis ensuite je
vais vous rappeler quand même la phrase
savoureuse un posteriori du Président on
est en avril 2019 donc à l'aube du
lancement de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat Emmanuel Macron dit ce
qui sortira de cette convention je m'y
engage sera soumis sans filtre soit on
vote du Parlement soit à référendum soit
à application réglementaire directe
résultat il y a eu effectivement un
projet de loi c'est vrai en juillet
dernier mais alors pour le sans filtre
c'est
chapitre 13 et 20 mesures les
associations sont pas d'accord mais en
tout cas moins de 20 mesures prises in
extenso de la convention pour mettre
dans le projet de loi du coup pendant le
vote du projet loyer il y a eu beaucoup
de manifestations parce que les citoyens
voyaient que ça leur échappait et puis
au final on va dire la moitié peut-être
des propositions inspirées de la
convention climat pourquoi je dis
inspirer parce qu'elles ont été
retravaillées et très souvent édulcoré
et une Chine et le président qui
rappelez-vous avait dit face caméra j'ai
changé j'ai compris l'importance de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
finalement mais à son passif c'est un
énorme échec d'Emmanuel Macron cette
convention citoyenne qui finalement n'a
été qu'un théâtre de cette démocratie
participative qu'il avait promise
parmi les mesures je pense que vous
savez approuvé ce que vient de dire
Laetitia cru pas mais il y a la Renault
de qui soutient la candidature
d'Emmanuel Macron on va on va passer
mais quand même plus chiant oui je suis
je pense que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
je suis pour la proportionnelle au
Parlement à l'Assemblée nationale une
proportionnelle la plus large possible
et au Sénat nous avons déjà la
proportionnelle pas systématique mais à
ce moment-là pas besoin de conventions
citoyenne c'est ça si il y a de la
protection il y a un problème dans notre
pays c'est que le système majoritaire
exclut le perd tous les perdants alors
les perdants ont le droit de s'exprimer
bon c'est un autre débat mais
effectivement c'était intéressant sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments je
voudrais vous entendre quand même Jérôme
durable parce que c'était l'une des
préconisations de la convention climat
il y a eu un chantier on va dire amorcé
par la ministre Emmanuel wargon que
propose votre candidate à Hidalgo pour
accélérer en la matière c'est vraiment
un des aspects importants je crois de
son de son programme oui sur
environnementale elle a cette
spécificités qu'elle considère qu'il
faut investir dans les chantiers
environnement eux-mêmes et autant dans
la dimension sociale et elle considère
que la rénovation thermique des
logements notamment elle doit aller
grands trains que on doit passer d'ici
2050 à 22 millions de logements 760 par
an avec un préfinancement et d'ailleurs
à une réflexion qui est assez
identique sur les mobilités
on voit bien qu'il y a une certaine de
personnes de population qui n'ont pas
les moyens de prendre en charge
l'investissement initial elle propose de
s'appuyer sur la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations pour organiser le prêt
financement de la rénovation et avoir
cette politique très volontariste à
l'échelle nationale en termes de
rénovation est-ce que je peux quand même
rajouter le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron avec
un peu de tristesse de mélancolie ou de
déception mais que tout est manuel
Macron est là son bilan mental c'est
tout et le contraire de tout
c'est-à-dire que beaucoup d'annonces peu
de résultats ça résume finalement sa
présidence ça résume sans quinquennat et
c'est un peu comme ça sur tous les
sujets donc sur la question
environnementale et climatique plus
particulièrement si on repart sur le
même système alors on va encore perdre
50 alors il y a dans le programme des
années que j'adore pas tout à fait la
même chose mais bon la rénovation
énergétique c'est où thermique c'est
vraiment très important il y a une autre
proposition commune et on va terminer ce
débat là-dessus nous reste 5 minutes
c'est un ISF climatique on va écouter
Yannick Jadot et Anne Hidalgo il y a
quand même quelques nuances regardez
mais c'est bien sûr l'ISF qui sera
entièrement dédié à un fond qui sera un
fond d'accompagnement de la transition
écologique notamment pour les plus
modestes il devient climatiques parce
que les patrimoines financiers
aujourd'hui sont la principale raison
pour laquelle les plus riches
émettent cinq fois plus de CO2 que les
Français en moyenne elle est à barrage
votre ESF climatique sera-t-il plus
efficace que celui d'animalgo alors il
permet de taxer celles et ceux qui
polluent le plus donc les plus riches
avec un patrimoine et donc on verra
aussi les actifs contenus dans ce
patrimoine qui ont une incidence sur le
réchauffement climatique et donc d'avoir
aussi un peu un bonus malus finalement
avec cette ISF climatique non seulement
c'est réta rétablit pardon la justice
sociale mais en plus ça permet
directement d'aller
un taxer les plus gros pollueurs puisque
on a véritablement une inégalité 10% des
plus riches qui polluent 5 fois plus que
la moyenne des Françaises et des
Français donc là il y a il y a un sujet
un sujet parce que c'est 50% des
Françaises et des Français en réalité
Patis du comportement et des actifs de
ces 10% les plus riches et je voudrais
juste revenir sur la convention
citoyenne pour pour le climat non
seulement ça a été un très bel exercice
démocratique mais ça a été aussi un très
bel exercice je vais dire d'éducation
populaire et c'est pas pour rien que de
nombreux de nombreuses personnes qui ont
participé à la Convention citoyenne pour
le climat on rejoint la campagne de ni
Yannick Jadot notamment William hawkente
qui pilote toute cette dimension
démocratique aussi au sein de de la
campagne et donc nous avons vraiment
fait notre les propositions nous
emportons un certain nombre notamment
sur la rénovation thermique des
logements et sur cette rénovation il
faut qu'elle soit sans
frais pour les ménages les plus modestes
et puis qu'elles puissent accompagner
aussi des projets territoriaux d'emploi
qui est de formation
comment vous accueillez une proposition
comme je suis complètement aussi la
toute forme d'ISF
qui n'obtiennent jamais le résultat
obtenu on l'a vu qu'en François
Mitterrand a créé l'IGF puis ensuite
l'ISF qui l'a rétabli il a découragé
l'entreprenariat on parle de la
désindustrialisation de la France mais
c'est parce que des industriels ont
préféré vendre leur entreprise que de
continuer à payer vous parliez du
logement je laisse terminer vous le
logement rapporte-moi je ne sais pas si
vous le savez mais si vous construisez
pour donner en location vous rapporte ça
vous gagne du 3 ou 4%, très bien
aujourd'hui mais si vous avez un isf1 et
demi il ne vous reste rien parce que cet
ISF non seulement il faut le payer mais
il faut gagner de l'argent et on paye
des impôts sur l'argent que l'on gagne
pour payer l'ISF c'est une histoire de
fou ça décourage l'investissement mais
là on l'a bien compris ISF climatique
pourquoi une telle mesure
parce que il y a un enjeu de cohésion
sociale
les gilets jaunes c'est un son c'est un
sujet environnemental et il est pas
normal que la transition écologique
énergétique climatique elle ne soit
ouverte qu'à ceux qui peuvent se payer
une confiture bio à 6,50 € et rouler en
voiture électrique et il y a dans ce
pays des gens des ruraux qui ont besoin
de voiture qui n'ont pas de borne donc
c'est les voitures thermiques qui ont
des logements qui sont plus vieux que
ceux qu'on peut trouver en zone urbaine
qui ont besoin d'être renommée et donc
du coup il faut assurer cette cette
péréquation cette égalité cette justice
et l'ISF climatique il permet de faire
tenir la société ensemble et on parlait
d'agriculteurs d'agriculture tout à
l'heure sur les sujets agricoles aussi
il s'agit pas seulement de culpabiliser
ceux qui ne sont pas entrés dans la dans
la transition écologique il faut que
l'État se donne les moyens de faire
différentes tout le monde et donc l'ISSF
ça permet ça et quand Anne Hidalgo parle
de leasing social pour permettre aussi
pour l'accès aux véhicules électriques
c'est très important quand vous êtes
dans un territoire rural comme le bien
ou en ville que vous n'êtes pas
propriétaire d'un pavillon comment vous
faites pour brancher votre voiture il y
a pas de borne donc faut investir dans
les bornes anidalgool propose et surtout
quand vous avez un petit salaire allez
acheter une voiture électrique qui vous
fera faire des économies toute l'année
ça n'est pas possible donc le leasing
social le permettra merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat